well let me welcome everyone here
tonight i'm professor steve west from
the Department of History on behalf of
the department of history and our
co-sponsors for tonight of tonight's
event the Graduate Student Association
and the association of history graduate
students we are very pleased to have
with us tonight dr. Lucy barber dr.
barber holds the PhD from brown
university has taught at the University
of California at Davis she's currently
an archivist at the California State
Archives and has consulted with the
Historical Society of Washington on
their new museum for the city dr. barber
is here tonight to discuss with us her
new book marching on Washington the
forging of an American political
tradition since the book was published a
few months ago dr. barber has made quite
a few appearances in the media she has
been on MSNBC she's been on PBS newshour
with jim lair she's been on NPR's talk
of the nation among many others what has
kept our so busy is that this is a book
that brings a very important historical
perspective to a very timely topic
public marches obviously have attracted
a good deal of attention recently
because of demonstrations against the
impending war it appears on Iraq this
summer I imagine dr. barber may only
find herself busier as we approach the
40th anniversary of the probably the
most famous march on Washington the 1963
March for jobs and freedom what makes
her book not just a timely book but a
very important and good one is the
historical perspective that she brings
to the topic I think most Americans
today certainly I think most of those of
us here in Washington take marching on
Washington as an established and regular
fact of political life but during the
1890s when the first large
March took place it was regarded by many
Americans and certainly by those in
authority as an illegitimate and even
potentially insurrectionary act in her
book dr. barber starts with that 1894
March and examines five other marches
over the course of the 20th century to
demonstrate the development of this
American political tradition and how
marching on Washington has shaped
politics and public culture here in
Washington and in the nation these are
all fascinating and important questions
and I'm sure you're eager to hear more
about them so let me ask you to join me
in welcoming dr. Lucy barber thank you
Steve thank you all for coming here I'm
very glad to be here at Catholic where
my good friend John sweet has been
teaching for many years and so I have
learned much from him and much about
this institution so it's very
interesting to finally see the place
since I've only heard about it from a
distance of course coming to Washington
is not so unfamiliar for me I have did
many years of research obviously in
connection with this book but I am also
someone's asking me just before about
whether or not I had Washington ties and
I am someone who came from a family that
is tied to Washington on my father's
side both his parents came from
Washington and lived here and and that
also ties into a question that I think
is very pertinent to and has asked all
the time these days is is why write a
book on the history of marching on
Washington and the way I think about
that now is there's two answers one
personal and one more intellectual so
i'll start with the personal i come from
a family of people who march
as I did my research I discovered the
name of my great-grandmother among the
women suffrages who had supported the
cause of the National Woman's Party
though she drew the line when they
decided to start picketing the White
House in Pickett's that were sodic
aureus in comparison to pickets of today
they would scarcely attract a blink she
however thought that that was a shameful
break with tradition and withdrew her
membership in the National Woman's Party
my parents as students went on their
second date to the youth March for
integrated schools one of the series of
marches that were held by civil rights
activists in the 1950s this was in 1958
and as I started this book there was a
little family debate among my mother and
father about whether or not my father
had been at the 1963 march on washington
for jobs and freedom my father claimed
that he had been my mother reminded him
that that was unlikely since he was
teaching in Indiana and had recently my
brother had recently been born one of
those examples of how people sometimes
create an attachment to an historical
event that may not be quite appropriate
and then I myself began marching at a
relatively early age as I start
mentioned in the preface to marching on
Washington the my earliest march on
Washington took place when I was around
six years old and I don't actually
remember clearly this event I'm sure
like others of you you have childhood
events that you know you took part in
but the only reason you know you took
part in it is because there's home
movies or for your generation Home
Videos of it so this march on washington
in 1971 on april twenty fourth and
indeed that was the name of the march
suggesting how come in marches on
washington had become by that time
it was simply called the April 24th
March it was against the Vietnam War
took place on a spring day and there's
pictures of me with my father with his
super 8 camera shooting footage of it
and my brother and I both standing
around somewhat young for the crowd but
carrying our out now signs and so this
personal history definitely is part of
why I write wrote this book it seemed to
me crucial at times in order to express
my political views on any number of
issues from controlling the use of new
healer power to expressing my views
about abortion rights to march to
demonstrate and even at times to risk
arrest but when I came to think about
this topic I also came to it as a
scholar I was a student of a number of
wonderful historians who came from both
political history Jim Patterson and
social history Jack Thomas and the
combination in through the medium of
women's history Mary Jo Buell and this
combination of scholars helped me see
that what I really wanted to do when I
came to write first the dissertation and
then in a major revision this book was
to do a topic in American history that
would allow us to appreciate the way in
which American citizens ordinary
American citizens have influence on
national politics I felt that in the
atmosphere of today in which it feels
very easy to assume that because of
declining voter participation because of
the clear influence of money and on
politics big businesses that there
needed to be
attention drawn to the way in which
people participated in politics and in
national politics there are any number
of wonderful studies that look closely
at local politics from the I point of
participants but it is harder and as I
discovered when I tried to craft the
stuff study it's harder sometimes to
grasp how ordinary Americans petitions
participate in national politics over a
long period so as I grappled with
choosing topics and I kept running into
amazing examples of marches on
washington in the midst of other topics
i was exploring whether it was in a
student paper that was written for me in
a class on the march on washington for
jobs and freedom in which i had that
feeling somewhat familiar to most people
who have taught of being extraordinarily
excited by what was on the page but
wishing for ever so much more which
wasn't on the page and wanting to know
more and finding myself wanting to
really understand this event which had
become so iconic for us all we all know
that i have a dream speech we can all
pitch your martin luther king if you
didn't already know it he was on a stamp
recently for the i have a dream speech
and you will be seeing him over and over
again this summer as we come on two the
40th year anniversary of that speech so
i felt that it was crucially important
to look at these events and find a way
to study them that would remind us of
how they related to each other because
one of the things i kept thinking was
wait why why why haven't we figured out
what's the relationship there's all
these different marches I keep running
across them but then when I went around
to look and say where's the book that
tells me what's the role on marching on
Washington or what's the history there
was no book there was no
died and so it seemed to me increasingly
important to try and do that kind of
study to try to figure out the
connections between these different
moments of political demonstrations so
that's the combination of why I came to
write this book and what I want to do
here today is use some examples from
three marches in the of the ones that I
look at in detail in this in my book on
on the whole tradition to examine the
most crucial question especially today
especially at this moment the question
of does marching on Washington make a
difference does it matter this comes up
all the time I wrote a piece that was
published in a variety of forums that
said marches can change American
politics and this was a very somewhat
upbeat yes go March don't take it for
granted it's something to do regardless
of the issue it was not go march against
the proposed invasion it was March for
pro-life march for voting rights march
for the environment there's a reason to
do it and I got a response from one
woman in LA who said you know what
marches make me tired I'm sick of
marches you said that they inspire
people they just make me exhausted they
take up too much time we really ought to
be just working on local organizing
don't bother they're not you shouldn't
write this kind of stuff I'm
exaggerating a bit but she was clearly
negative
and this was different than the negative
comments where they accused me of being
a communist sympathizer and those I just
deleted I actually wrote back to her and
said I appreciated her comments and felt
that I was writing for a different
audience and that I understood as an
experienced activist she might want to
stay home from a few secretly thinking
maybe you should stay home from a lot
for a while and get a rest so I want to
talk about this ken marches on
Washington make a difference and what
can we learn by looking at the past
obviously as I I you already know my big
answer which is yes so it's more what do
we learn over time and why and how do
they make a difference so if we go back
to that march in 1894 that was talked
about by steve west that marked by
coxey's army as they were called a group
of unemployed men led by two rather
strange and individuals a mild-mannered
businessman named jacob coxy from ohio
and carl brown a flamboyant labor
organizer newspaper editor cartoon
driver supposedly a participant in the
Buffalo Bill Wild West Show we go back
to 1894 and think about what these
people thought they were doing we
realized it was a very different time
they believed Carl Brown and Jacob coxy
believed that if they gathered together
their supporters and if they walked to
Washington in what they called a
petition in boots that they would come
to Washington and that they would
present their demand for an enormous
public road building program
on a scale that was unimaginable but
these men believed that as they came and
they showed themselves as citizens in
the people's capital that the members of
Congress would listen to them they were
wrong they came to Washington they set
up camp and brightwood racing track they
charged admission they were not very
rich as you might expect people flocked
out to see them but the Washington Post
described them as being not unlike a
third-rate circus and indeed they were
roundly attacked for both the idea and
the threat that they seem to pose the
whole idea was attacked the editors of
the Portland telegram called the mirror
proposal a sign of fatal blood poisoning
in the Republic they attacked the
leaders they describe Carl Brown as a
read of as deep a die as any that ever
trod at haymarket Haymarket being the
sign of a very controversial meeting by
anarchists in Chicago in 1888 which
ended up with a conflict between the
police that led to charges on eight
anarchists who were sentenced to death
though some of them were not present at
Haymarket and many of them some of them
were eventually pardoned so they clearly
thought of this group as brown as a
dangerous group in the eyes of
traditional politics and the
participants as a group
were no better they were dismissed by
the editors of the independent not yet
quite the progressive journal that it
was to become a few years later they
were dismissed as an army of tramps and
the editor declared that they ought to
have no influence whatsoever on
legislation or Congress and indeed they
did not belong to the bone and sinew of
the country but they didn't just use
rhetoric against coxey's army they use
law when the cot sees army marched down
Pennsylvania Avenue Jacob coxy had
discovered that there were a number of
laws that were going to limit what he
thought he could do in Washington that
his people's capital was not so open to
him as he is had expected the police
chief had politely informed him that
there was a regulation passed in 1882
that forbid any organized group from
parading on the grounds of the capital
from carrying banners from making
speeches from using any part of that
public space surrounding the capital for
a political cause and that if you did so
you would be arrested so classy decided
that he was not willing to risk arrest
for all the participants of the march
they did not plan to march all onto the
grounds of the Capitol but he was
determined that he had the right as an
individual just like all these other
visitors who came to Washington and went
up the steps of the Capitol and went
inside the Capitol building and
sometimes even went in and lobbied and
spoke to congressman that he too had
a trite to say his piece at the Capitol
and when he did he was arrested they
decided for a variety of reasons not to
charge him with giving a speech they
recognized but that would be a pretty
obvious tension with the first amendment
granting the right of the people to
peaceably assemble and to petition the
government for a redress of grievances
but instead they charged him with
walking on the grass for this they were
fined and imprisoned for 20 days it's
not a small it's not quite the same as
what even today we people who engage in
civil disobedience get and it did rather
deflate the power of coxey's army which
though they stayed in washington for the
summer had a difficult time figuring out
quite what to do with themselves and
eventually were dispersed partially by
being bribed with train rides home so it
was clear that the First Amendment's
guarantee of the right of the people
peaceably to assemble did not at that
time extend to these citizens who wish
to use those public spaces in Washington
so it would appear that this March made
no difference but it did plant a germ of
an idea in many people's heads and in
that way it did make a difference it
made people appreciate that perhaps
there was a reason to use the public
spaces of the Capitol to petition for
your cause perhaps not exactly as
coxey's army had but in ways that might
be powerful for opponents of coxey's
army this was quite disturbing one
senator
cautioned his colleagues as he argued
for a more repressive action to be taken
against them that if they tolerated the
march that it is quite possible that it
may become a habit to make pilgrimages
annually to Washington and endeavour to
dominate Congress by the physical
presence of the people how little did he
know he was going to be right and indeed
he was to some extent right in the wake
of coxey's army groups began to think
more and more about using public
protests in the capital as a means of
furthering their cause and you can see
this in the evolution from the nineteen
in the early 1900s through the 1920s and
1930s there is a growing acceptance of
the notion that certain kinds of marches
on Washington certain kinds of
demonstrations I should say because that
term had not become accepted yet the
notion of a march on Washington was not
what they were called yet you notice the
coxey's army called themselves a
petition in boots tying themselves
directly to the petition in 1913 when
the suffragist came they were a parade
and pageant tying themselves more to a
tradition of both genteel display of
good virtue and also of military parades
down Pennsylvania Avenue asst were a
common occurrence but nevertheless when
there was controversy about where they
should parade a police chief suggested
that Pennsylvania Avenue with its
collection of saloons and Bower ease was
not the right place for dignified women
and instead suggested they marched down
16th Avenue which he saw as a
respectable location 16th streets sorry
as a respectable location
they protested vehemently and they won
the right to march on Pennsylvania
Avenue and the Washington Post no fan of
suffrage supported their claim by
equating the suffrages to any other
citizen male or female and likewise in
1932 when veterans of World War one came
to Washington seeking immediate payment
of what they considered their just
compensation for serving the country
during World War one the march that
became known as the bonus March when
they came in 1932 they were tolerated
they were treated with kindness
President Hoover arranged for the army
to give them tense a place to camp
opened up the Navy hospital for them to
be treated the superintendent of police
at that time a man named pehlan
glassford actually had the distinct and
somewhat strange role of being both the
police chief of Washington and the
treasurer of the group behind the bonus
March so he was simultaneously in charge
of policing them and making sure that
their financial arrangements stayed on
the up-and-up so there grew to be a more
common acceptance of the idea that
political protest was something that was
acceptable and there were small gains
from each of those demonstrations and
direct policy terms but one of the
difficulties that I've struggled with
with this book one of those interesting
ironies i would say in historical study
the kind of thing that makes you really
have to grasp
complexity and not settle for simple
stories is that if you want to look for
a march that made a difference a march
that resulted in immediate and concrete
changes in federal policy then you have
to look to what I call the March that
did not happen it was the threatened
Negro march on Washington of 1941 that
generated the most immediate and most
obvious result of change in policy
resulted in President Roosevelt issuing
an executive order executive order 8802
that was the first federal order
prohibiting racial discrimination by
contractors outside of the federal
government but defense contractors this
is significant there had already been
during the New Deal orders that on paper
said the federal government should not
discriminate on the grounds of race
these were not completely enforced by
any means but to expand the reach of the
federal government to say that the
federal government was going to
intervene in cases of racial
discrimination in private business was a
new thing and it came because of a
skillful threat to march on Washington
the organizers of this March were
different folks than the people who'd
mark organized coxey's army a Phillip
Randolph an african-american labor
organizer had years of experience in
organizing and in protesting he had
developed new associations he had led
the Brotherhood of sleeping car porters
to recognition by both the Pullman
Company giving african-americans very
real place in the labor movement and he
had built alliances with many other
African American leaders of the time he
was a classic race man as the term was
of the time and when he looked around in
1941 and he listened to his colleagues
notice and comment and complain and go
to Congress and go to the President and
say look what is going on our country is
preparing for war we are in need of
workers we are in need of experienced
soldiers and your administration is
tolerating segregation in the military
that results in inefficiencies and
results in discrimination against people
who deserve promotions and new roles and
looking around at defense contractor
after defense contractor who refuses to
hire african-americans sometimes because
they say their fellow workers won't
tolerate it and that was most certainly
the case and sometimes simply because it
wasn't their practice Randolph decides
that he is going to organize what he
calls
calls a math mammoth machine of mass
action with a terrific striking power
and he labeled this effort the Negro
march on washington for defense jobs for
defense he wasn't shy he didn't cloak
his march in any other rhetoric this
wasn't a petition in boots this was not
a parade this was not a new type of
lobbying as one of the leaders of the
bonus March wanted to call it but this
was a mass action that was going to
change America and he organized a very
effective coalition and they started
organizing and they got black fraternal
groups and black churches and black
newspapers to sign up and endorse the
effort and by late may of nineteen forty
one for a march scheduled for June 1941
President Roosevelt was getting quite
concerned he described himself as much
upset about the upcoming protest and he
appealed to some of his friends who were
african-american to stop the March now
these genteel requests did nothing
Randolph ignored them
he rammed off roosevelt then decided to
see what would happen if he made some
concessions he had an executive office
he had a memorandum issued that said
that defense contractors really
shouldn't discriminate but it really
wasn't right it wasn't the right policy
this had no force but it was sort of an
advisory memo he did this then he sent
his wife Eleanor up to wash up to New
York where the march was being organized
and had her meet with the leaders and
she did her best to try to persuade them
that Roosevelt was serious about this
memorandum and that it was really going
to take effect and they said a half no
way we're not doing it we're not going
to change it we've got our plans we're
going to march silently up Pennsylvania
Avenue we're going to go by the White
House and then we're going to assemble
at the Lincoln Memorial and we are going
to show the people of this country and
the nation and the world that
african-american citizens are not
treated with equality we're doing it
Thanks for meeting with us by
so then Roosevelt decided that he had to
meet with them but this was the only way
they were going to get action and he did
and it was quite a meeting it was a
historic meeting not only the president
was there but the secretaries of the war
in the Navy all the major officials
involved with the fence program and a
Phillip Randolph and Walter White the
president of the National Association
for colored people even with this sense
of gathering all these important busy
people in June in late June of 1941
those of you who know military history
well we'll know that this is a period in
which the Nazi government is in the
process of planning to break their pact
with the Soviet Union and as a on the
brink of invading the Soviet Union this
is a period in which Poland is under
it's about has just fallen this is a
crucial moment in the war and all these
men are called into the office to meet
with these two men and Roosevelt starts
by trying to tell stories and jokes and
Randolph has to interrupt them and say
that you know we're here to talk about
the problem of negras participation in
the armed services in the defense
industries so r and Roosevelt tried to
just say well you know I'm opposed to
this and he started listing his reasons
he said that the March would make other
people think that the Negroes are
seeking to exercise force to compel the
government to do certain things with
their silent march and their assemblage
at the Lincoln Memorial he did express
concern that was probably appropriate
that such a march might cause race riots
and the still very segregated climate of
Washington DC and then he complained his
final complain in this series was that
if the Negro March was held he was
afraid that soon the Irish and Jewish
people would also take to the streets of
Washington so in this series of
complaints he true rehearsed the
traditional arguments against why people
should not use the streets of Washington
for their political causes that it was
an inappropriate use of pressure but it
might inspire violence and worst of all
that they might encourage everybody to
protest in Washington Randolph said so
what were respectable were dignified we
have a good cause were coming so then
Roosevelt tried to figure out what the
threat was he turned Randolph and he
said how many people do you plan to
bring and Randolph said in his deep
voice 100,000 mr. president and
Roosevelt turned to alter right who he
trusted more and asked water how many
people really well March tell me the
real story white replied that he
expected no less than 100,000
they stared at each other and then
Roosevelt started to negotiate and he
committed to put the force and weight of
his office behind the effort to secure
jobs for qualified Negroes and he left
by proposing they create a committee
which then it sounds a good at first but
they managed to hammer out an agreement
in which this committee the fair
employment practices committee created
by the executive order would actually
have the power to discipline companies
who discriminated in defense contracts
so in this moment in this key moment
this march on Washington most certainly
did make a difference but it came at the
cost of canceling it
once it was signed on jun 25th Randolph
proceeded to fly to the meeting of the
National Association for colored people
announced for the Advancement of Colored
People announced that the march was off
a call was made out on the radio
stations that touched most
african-americans and they called off
the march the Negro march on Washington
so this March would prove to be
extraordinarily effective it used the
rhetoric of citizenship they used an
international threat of international
embarrassment and it used a legitimate
claim to put pressure on the President
and it also used the capital spaces that
threatened to use the capital spaces in
a way that would prove especially
embarrassing to the United States on the
evil for the notion of African Americans
marching peaceably up Pennsylvania
Avenue and then assembling at the
Lincoln Memorial using that space to
display their place in the nation when
that place was so treated unequally was
incredibly powerful
but could it be recreated and this is
what I will conclude with is to think
some about could that happen again that
special power there were special
circumstances it was the eve of war it
was a situation in which there were
grounds to negotiate it wasn't situation
which who had extremely savvy organizers
who were willing to play a very tough
game and in its wake in some ways I
think that potential was no longer as
possible and if we think about the 1963
March just briefly and some of the
characteristic characteristics of it we
can think about why that potential
became less powerful on one hand one
thing that became clear is that future
presidents did not want to be put in
this position and they decided that
would be better to not get so concerned
about any potential demonstration that
they would need to go to such effort to
force its cancellation so they got much
better at figuring out whether or not
such marches would result in real
threats and you can see the development
in the wake of this March and over the
1940s and 50s of much more sophisticated
plans on the part of police forces the
military the various different groups
and officials with authority over this
capital on how to respond to marches the
other part was that that legacy the
legacy of the threat of making a march
powerful because it had so many people
that conversation about a hundred
thousand people became an increasingly
important part of future marches we all
know about how how many people you get
to come to your march becomes often the
most important part of the discussion
and you could see that clearly in the
planning of
1963 march on Washington they wanted to
be big they were committed to being big
they made claims that they were going to
be big and they were big but if you want
to be big you've got to do some things
that make it more difficult to have that
kind of confrontation that immediacy won
the march on washington for jobs and
freedom was partially designed to put
pressure on congress for the civil
rights bill but they realized once they
started organizing it that their initial
idea that they would have it as soon as
they started debating the march on the
civil rights bill in congress was going
to prove difficult because you want to
know what day that would happen so you
have to pick a date you can't just have
a march on any day and expect a hundred
thousand people to show up that quickly
at least not in 1963 it may prove this
weekend that 4 weeks planning is
possible to get a hundred thousand
people to the city of Washington but not
in 1963 and not for a March that
involved integrating both blacks and
white into the march and they also in
order to get that turn out they had to
be determined to be peaceful and in this
they turn to close cooperation with the
Kennedy administration to ensure it and
that meant it took away that element of
surprise and independence that the
earlier organizers had the result was
the forging in my mind and I use that
word as what it should mean a word
forging is something that is hard to do
you have to forge metal you have to
bring things together and that's what
organizers over the course of a century
did in making the tradition of marching
on Washington but in making of forging a
tradition you also give up something
you give up that surprise factor if you
want to be big and peaceful you give up
that sense of radicalism that inspired
some of the earlier marches and you also
have the obscure and somewhat difficult
to deal with fact that they now are seen
is so traditional that almost anyone can
on the surface accept them I've been on
a number of Colin shows about my book
and people call up and say things like
well you know I get it you know it's
okay these anti-war protestors are you
know they're fine they've got their
right to march that's you know I'm not
but I'm not going to argue with you
about that but you know they've got this
problem or that problem and when
Condoleezza Rice was asked you know is
the administration concerned about these
protests are we doing it are they doing
anything to stop these protests she said
oh no oh no people have the right to
protest it's not a problem we don't mind
it so there can be that air of non
concern but did not have that same
poignancy of some of the earlier
demonstrations but nevertheless I would
still argue firmly that this tradition
is still very powerful and this custom
this method of political participation
is extraordinarily important over the
years a protest people have learned to
make Washington into a people's capital
they have made public spaces including
the mall this many of the areas around
the capital to a great extent
Pennsylvania Avenue spaces that almost
any group can gain access to if they're
willing to be peaceful and not too
disruptive
and this is a space that can be used for
a variety of political purposes by
making it something that is accepted
grips from a far greater range of
political persuasions now march on
Washington than ever would have been
imagined in the 1930s or the 1940s the
variety of groups and they can be used
both to build movements to confirm
movements and to inspire others to think
seriously about political causes and
those others are sometimes the person
standing next to you in a demonstration
or the person watching you on television
and sometimes the president and
sometimes the citizens of another
country to take inspiration from the
Washington citizens or the citizens of
America expressing their views on an
issue so I think that over the years it
has become a tradition but it's a
tradition that still has the potential
to influence our country and ourselves
so thank
and um so I just gotta say we've got
time for some questions much to ask the
people speak up I will seal I will seal
them and and do my best with them yes I
happen to have remembered the march on
Washington very very clearly something
you said just brought this to my mind on
the day of the march downtown Washington
with the exception of the police was
absolutely deserted businesses everybody
close up there was such a fear that
violence would break out my goodness was
most peaceful think you could imagine
subsequent marches on Washington I don't
know whether the local business people
are getting easier Angeles but they
don't seem to close up and leave anymore
no I think that was I mean there was an
element in which there was a whole fear
atmosphere surrounding the march on
Washington despite these efforts on the
part of both the Kennedy administration
and especially the organizers to assure
everyone there was going to be no civil
disobedience there was going to be no
disruption but on the city commissioners
were quite concerned about it so they
actually passed unheard of resolution
banning the sale of alcohol on the day
of the march I mean they literally seem
to feel that like this group I mean they
seem to think that this group of African
Americans forgetting that many whites
were also going to participate we're
going to come down to Washington get
drunk and cause a riot so they actually
since Prohibition it's only time they
did this so there was an element of fear
and Kennedy despite being praising the
March proclaiming it was part of a great
tradition in American protest which I
was a bit of a historical recreation at
the time not completely aren't accurate
he did also have arranged for troops
to be moved up closer to the capital and
to ensure that there were adequate
police force the policemen were just
absolutely bored during the day the most
exciting thing that happened to them as
they all got food poisoning because they
didn't control the temperature on their
sandwiches so um that was um not the
best part of the day for them but other
than that they really didn't have very
much to do except direct traffic oh yes
the mall because especially since before
public space and people
podium for their large
but also in very recent years it's been
changing quite drastically as you know
and we cite in your book the World War
two
the larger space will now be off limits
but also the Park Service's had to
restrict demonstrations in certain
dogs sacred zone I want to come
now the security idea
measured putting up the capital
essentially to come
closed off Pennsylvania
paper about rejection beloved
how
really having achieved this great place
is a public forum but now it seemed
slowly being broken down yeah i'm i'm
equally concerned about that process and
very concerned about the seeming
intransigence of the Park Service on
these issues on been repeated requests
to consider the legacy and the
historical tradition of marching on
Washington and the use of the mall as
they plan for these new monuments and
earlier proposals had clearly stated
that there were going to be no more
monuments that it was time to stop this
before the mall got to fall um and one
of the things that I think is important
is to understand the history of the mall
in thinking about that the mall was
originally designed to be an open space
though it wasn't designed for the people
it was designed for the military it was
supposed to be where they would parade
and practice their drills it became a
park well it was a swamp and then a park
and then it only in the 1930s did they
clear it and as soon as they cleared it
you start to see it used for these big
events so people quickly grasped its
power when you think about the moment in
which Marian Anderson is prohibited from
from refuses to sing before segregated
audience at the Daughters of the
American Revolution she they turn to the
Lincoln Memorial and they're able to
have a huge number of people gather
there for a wonderful concert that is a
state of both a political statement and
a moral statement at the same time and
over time the Negro march on Washington
people are going to use that same
tradition later groups come use them all
over and over again and really enshrine
it and see its potential as this space
and political leaders become tolerant at
42 they this whole regulation that
prohibits use of the capital space is
not overturned by the Supreme Court
until nineteen seventy-two but in the
mean
I'm even quite surprising figures had
allowed marchers to use the west side of
the Capitol to have their speakers on so
that they could use the rest of the
expanse for their demonstrations and so
both in practice and then what people
clearly wanted to use the mall quickly
was claimed as this space and without
preserving that I mean part of the
purpose of the National Park Service's
to preserve historical legacies and yet
their seeming not to they are going to
now put a little marker where Martin
Luther King gave is I have a dream
speech but I'm not sure that was
particularly necessary since almost all
of us see that image over and over again
including your fourth graders it's not
the worst thing but it's just pretty
token I would have much rather has made
the space clear as a memorial to him
than to have a plan so yes today marches
on Washington
is the zone is more of just a way for
interest groups to advertiser police
than to end that day today they have
lost its potency to create change I
think that it really is a different
style of creating change so yes you
could call them interest groups of
course any group that can manage to pull
people together and do something
together have a common interest it's a
term that sometimes is thrown around is
sort of a bad word I personally think
that that's part of them democracy that
there are going to be people that have
common interests and they come together
and they want to influence things and
they I think that they are you sometimes
to affirm themselves and advertise their
cause but that's part of the nature of
having a political debate that includes
a wide range of people in American
politics if you had if the only people
that are allowed to speak it likes the
people at the time of coxey's army were
the elected representatives I think that
would narrow the range of political
debate in the country and so that that's
would be a loss to the nature of the
working of American democracy that's not
to say that I can't you know sometimes
wonder you know I mean that I'm working
on this book and watch on TV that in
1993 or something like that that the
association of travel agents well know
the travel agents were marching on
Washington now maybe I don't take travel
agents seriously enough and I ought to
revive my feeling of them as a nun
represented at a mistreated group but
you know they were having their annual
conference they didn't like some new law
that was like regulating this and that
it's fine with me i don't mind that that
march why it showed up on providence TV
i have no idea i think maybe there was
some luck lango i didn't get and but in
normal course of things that perhaps
would not
track that much attention and I'm not
particularly concerned about that
problem so I think that yeah that's the
way I look at it other people can call
them a waste of money and move on to a
different type of political
participation it's not for everyone yes
Jim the biggest one of the wall and
another scaring 14 people ahead of time
was the medium in March and I wonder if
you have comments about that thoughts
about an ounce
um yeah I mean I sort of changed my mind
on the Million Man March to be quite
frank the time I was bit cynical about
it I I thought not not out of just a
sort of intuitive negative louis
farrakhan thought though he's not a very
he did not give a speech that equaled
earlier speeches at the time but but
because i was like they're stuck in this
notion of well you got if you're gonna
have a marg you ought to have a set of
demands and it ought to be related to
federal policy and you know let's get
let's get real here I mean what's the
point but when I thought about it and
when I've seen how it's it really seemed
to resonate with the people who came how
it inspired other marchers how it
inspired other marches I really started
to come to have a greater acceptance of
this notion that part of the point of
marching to do a public display of an
identity that is not portrayed as people
think it should be in American culture I
I think there's much to be said it is
similar to the Promise Keepers though
the Promise Keepers had this sort of
reputation of being the sort of among
some people of being a sort of group
that met in sports arenas and just for
doing this muscular Christianity that
really didn't have any you know
legitimacy and showing themselves in
public no longer charging a huge
admission fee letting everyone came gave
them a different portrayal and I felt
the same way about the Million Man March
it opened up an organization the Nation
of Islam that had been closed and it may
not I don't think it necessarily changed
the Nation of Islam but it changed I
think a lot of ways that
african-american men felt about each
other and the way they were portrayed in
the press and and helped inspire
subsequent marches that seemed to be
very powerful for their participants
yeah the last wish to suggest
looking at this this particular forum
political participation Bolivian
politics in general that is that there
are perhaps two axes that are present in
the analysis and that is one the sort of
demand oriented that is we have a listen
to bands we have legislative goals give
a point to our agenda and the other is
the existential here we are we exist the
people who are there find out what
others exist those who observe see that
they exist and I wondering if you can
buy it about those two axes when you can
make a
tell us something about how we can see
that historically that is do you think
they're just any given group that's out
there would be on one side or the other
words our historical trip I mean if I
can just tip my only and I haven't
thought about this early as much as you
but it seems to me the work we're moving
more towards the existential you know we
are here and you know it confirms us and
alike and in which of course you may
celebrate or lament that as you could
say that it's just identity politics
it's just fortuitous itself regarding it
it's disconnected from the truth of the
depository might say well the spectra
people movements developed and
ultimately achieve some sort of purchase
on yeah I mean I think I'm not sure I
can comment much more because you just
said my point so eloquently yourself I
think that is the way that I I think
that the thing to just always appreciate
is that there are a one of the virtues
of our country is to have a range of
methods a political expression we have
elected officials who report to us and
who we vote for and for whom we
influenced by in the poll except for in
the District of Columbia where you have
no national representation as I see on
your license plates every day um but in
the other sense so that we have that
form of political participation we have
the ability to write letters we have the
ability to form groups we have the
ability to raise money we have the
ability now to have virtual marches on
Washington and that those all those
methods are available to us and that
some of them are about creating bonds of
solidarity together I mean you know if I
look at the pictures that I took when i
went to pro-choice rallies part of it is
about reunions with my friends from
college and I mean I that's a common
thing that people do they come from all
over the country and they see their
friends and they're reminded of their
past and their future political wise and
then other people come you know and you
see others and you're like wow this is
amazing everyone always tells me these
stories of how i came to whether it's
the march on Washington or jobs or
freedom or this or that March I came all
the way from here and I just ran into
this person I hadn't seen them in years
and I mean that's that small politics
maybe but it's big politics when it gets
compounded and inspired I mean but I
think also in the terms of I wouldn't
say it I would have said and I do say in
my epilogue yes it's going more to
identity affirmative affirmation and
movement
building but then you turn around and
you look at what's happening with the
demonstrations against the question of
whether to invade Iraq and you can see
how demonstrations can be very driven by
immediate policy needs and policy
questions and I don't think it's I mean
indeed the complaints that I hear on
radio for people critical of them is oh
well they're not coherent these are
people there are many people marching
next to each other who do not agree on
other issues they do not just feel like
they're all with their brothers and
sisters and yet they feel a common
political mission on this issue and that
strikes me as still the possible forum
for whether it leads to direct change of
President Bush's policy I would still
say no it's not likely but it has
obviously changed other people's
policies and not just our marches but
other marches as well so oh I am
inspiring let me go to you thoughts
about the recent of marches on at least
like
that aren't necessarily government but
their political and the police's
complete the actions of the DC police
toward the protesters how that changes
the image of Washington as the people
sick um yeah um it's a cot that is that
is one of the things that I would argue
that partly because in Washington I
think particularly there has been this
creation of a tradition of marching on
Washington that much more depends on the
notion of a large peaceful march that
when people do plan these more
disruptive marches there is almost in
some ways more leeway for the Washington
police or if it's the park police or
depending on the area to crack down
harder even if in some cases it's not
within the bounds of legal process I
understand that there's litigation still
going on about the two thousand World
Bank protests here but it still seems
like there's a fair amount of sort of
general support for that notion that
that's not the right way to protest in
Washington smaller groups I mean what i
call rituals of civil disobedience where
you're not really intent on disrupting
where you go and sit in front of the
White House and you know that if you sit
there for 20 minutes the police will
come up to you and arrest you that I
think is perfectly within the bounds of
what Washington please no firmly how to
have all they negotiate with you they
figure it out you get some bills some
people decide not to give their name but
these disruptive protests are clearly
something that they don't want and
they're willing to do a lot to stop I
mean from pre-emptive search warrants to
declarations of court and off areas and
which they would not do for other
demonstrations and I in a way I do
believe that that's something the
Washington police has more right not i'm
not saying this is necessarily a
positive thing i'm just saying it is an
observational thing because of the
tradition of a different kind of protest
in the city
that kind of delineation is more
possible here than in other cities where
there isn't so firm of like this is a
custom that people use all the time so
now this violates that custom you know
when you go to Geneva or you go to this
obscure city in Switzerland as they also
had protests people there don't say this
shouldn't happen here because there's a
different way approach that interesting
that is legitimate and powerful here
they could say oh well maybe that's what
you gotta do to stop it you know if you
see them as the big bad guys you know
that's what you gotta do so it's I mean
it's an interesting problem for me and
obviously you know I'm concerned when
they're clearly violating our civil
liberties but on the other hand I'm I
personally went through my little stage
of thinking that oh it was ever so
wonderful to be as irritating as
possible as a protester and have moved
beyond that stage so perhaps I look at
some of them and say you know something
so irritating because i think you know i
can understand i've talked to police
officer it's irritating you carry your
15th person to a police fan you're
getting tired you know and I have some
sympathy for that that's a real thing
yes sir two questions one is in your
book tour when you give you a
presentation in other parts of the
country less sophisticated
country you get an appreciation for the
protest in Washington is sympathetic
until they think we're crazy
American as question number one the
other question is you barely touched on
it but the role of the media in this
whole process
whether they become more blase where you
have to become more dramatic in order to
get their attention their tendency to
undercount or over counts in reaction
etc um my sense is you know I'm not such
a world traveler as you might like to
imagine of me but my sense is that
people pretty generally have an image of
a kind of march on Washington that they
think is just fine they may not think
it's politically relevant to them they
may not think it is inspiring but a
large assemblage of people on the mall
in Washington is okay I mean when people
who were outraged by the anti-war
protests we're calling me up and more
challenged not by me because I'm not
quite the type but um by hosts on some
radio shows yeah like well are you
saying mission at March oh oh no I'm not
saying that I'm just saying you know
they're feeding saddam hussein's and
supporting his caused by marching so on
that question I think there is a um
there is I think I think it not it's not
something that just Washingtonians have
come to tolerate because I mean what
choice do you have or I think it's it is
more widespread than that and I mean it
partly because there are so many diverse
groups that have marched on Washington
but I mean I couldn't know it but I
think sort of a lot of people probably
know someone or know someone that has
marched on Washington and they think
that person is ok so it can't be all
crazies on the question of the media I
think that they are an incredibly
influential part of how marches in
Washington have been perceived through
time the coxey's army would not be
remembered except for the media decided
to cover it and it fits with media
conventions of the time
they liked at that time because of the
nature of reporting and the difficulties
of getting stories to have cereal
stories they would carry coverage of a
story over days days days I mean the
trial coverage of you know someone who
had an affair accompanied the coxey's
army march across Washington in the
newspaper and it just went on and on in
a detail that we would never imagine in
this age in which you know you get one
day and then you're done you know like
you know that's it and that fit and so
it created this whole it inspired others
because there was all this reporting
coxey's army which started off with
about 200 people about 500 more people
to join it in words inspiring people all
over what the united states to join the
march they're seizing trains in Oregon
and California to get to get to
Washington by May first so the media can
help a march immensely and during the
nineteen sixty-three march one of the
things I noticed in contrast to today
was how much they covered not just the
march but the organizing there are
reports on what they were thinking about
their strategy and that makes a big
difference in us understanding instead
of these events that are popping up and
then disappearing where you don't really
get a sense of what are the consequences
the controversies the issues that people
are grappling with that has tended to
disappear and I think that's partly
because television has a much different
sense of the medium I mean they covered
the march on Washington in 1963 live at
least one network did now I mean maybe
cable is going to change the world the
Million Man March got some live coverage
because of that because there's enough
networks to cover but not everybody can
watch it and mostly you're going to end
up with very very short reports that in
my mind 10 to reduce marches to how many
people showed up as if that is the only
criteria for whether something is
politically relevant and that I find is
too dismissive of the power of marching
in the back you've been
irritation are you contrive I've
participated going back
and early on you could get very close to
very important right up against the
White House static and so on but in this
new fortress mentality that has
developed in Washington we're not
allowed to get very close to those
buildings anymore are you concerned that
it's going to be given to push further
and further away until the march will be
coming over I am concerned I I think
there's two sides of it to me one thing
is that there was a real strategy on the
part of both the nineteen forty one
neighbor March organizers in the
nineteen sixty-three organizers to see
the value of using the space like the
mall and being somewhat separated from
both Congress and the White House as a
way of placing yourself in an
independent almost creating you know a
third branch you know I know there's so
many branches of government now we don't
know which term but here we are we're
over here and we're speaking to both of
you so that they sort of moved away from
the notion that getting up close which
was very important to early protesters
and came back again I mean that was
clearly key to anti-war protesters and
later protesters so I think you know you
can reimagine them and say it doesn't
matter so much and i think this the
tendency now for there to be more and
more protests in different locations at
the same time which is a testimony to
more to the resources and different
skills of organizers today makes it
somewhat different but it still does
it's kind of it's this is not when it's
not completely believable to me i mean i
have heard all I mean you know but I
mean I you know I i I'd love to go back
and talk to some of the people I've
talked to in the Park Police and in the
Department of Interior and so forth but
it's just it's not to me a scenario that
like has viability especially when you
do a special arrangement because of a
protest
I mean you know my understanding with
the code pink protest is that they
weren't allowed in areas that are
generally open to people and and in
which they were going to use in ways
that our standard procedure and that
they cracked down on them because they
were a demonstration now that seems to
me wrong I mean they're not different
and I don't think they're that likely to
be carried carrying a bomb or going to
be dead in a eating something and if
they were then that would be a different
security issue than location because
that would be could happen in many
places and I mean indeed the first
orders right after September 11 what
they focused on they did they quoted
that as the thread when they closed the
ellipse in Lafayette Park and stuff like
that and then they lifted it and I mean
I've got to say that I thought that was
reasonable I mean they did say no you
know they seem to come so much to their
senses but as they build these fences
and you know i mean it's it's amazing to
me you know i mean the boundaries are
getting wider and wider and this is in
light of new rulings from the court I
mean the Supreme Court just ruled in
2002 that the sidewalks of the Capitol
were a public forum and protected by the
rights of the people to use them because
tourists regularly walk on them now this
point is somewhat you know because of
the construction right now they aren't
open to the public but they're not just
they're not in my knowledge they weren't
originally going to be closed to the
public but if they are then there is the
court they have that space-time place
ruling legitimacy so I mean I have to
say that I think people need to pressure
them to think about what you know I mean
is this a serious threat I mean I work
in a building that you know we now have
new security provisions and you know
it's it's not they aren't sensible that
what people did because it was a
particular moment and hopefully at some
point people will be able to back back
and say
what do we really need if there's a real
threat here and I just don't see from my
perspective I don't see it i just got
asked the other night by someone who
teaches riot control and demonstrations
as whether or not i'd come in and talk
to his class that he teaches to military
officers and stuff like that and I was
like yes sir I would love to because I
want to learn that part I mean I read
those manuals from all the different
periods of time to see what people were
thinking about how do you control crowds
what do you do about demonstrations and
that was fascinating lesson and I want
to talk to them because that's part of
being educated as a scholar and a
citizen to understand their what their
thought processes on these issues so
that I can be more responsive but also
express my opinion intelligently so
that's what I hope for I'm afraid that I
what one more question and then yeah I
have hi could I
I'd like to know in the study of the
illustrations are watching you see this
your relationship between the way the
political system and such operation the
very democratic very open to able to
people are gravity this move moving away
and the type of demonstrations that have
come to Washington DC and we believe
that if what implements political
scientists believe that as the system is
more and more closing itself down to
real mass participation that that may
indeed lead to a different in a new type
of protest when you going back to 60s
demanding
bution other type of imagining of civil
rights um I most certainly think that
when there's there's gross disparities
and treatment of different types of
citizens that then there's protests that
highlight that kind of disparity I mean
that's clearly was one of the early uses
of Washington and a continuing use of
Washington so because it's such a potent
place to claim citizenship it's that's
one reason to use it but in terms of you
know dramatic shifts in the political
train you know I mean I know I might be
speaking blasphemy to me in comparison
to other countries the United States has
not had such a dramatic changes even in
the last century that during which this
tradition developed I think the 1960s it
was not so much of a closing down of a
system but of a sense that that there
was such a desperate need to highlight
causes that people turn to more radical
tactics I mean Nixon had many faults and
I'm not saying he was you know but he
was not the whole political system there
was still the opportunity to testify
there was still movements in Congress
there were still votes there were still
many other things I think it was the
spirit of the time between the civil
rights movement and the Vietnam
anti-vietnam war movement that made
people after working so hard on so many
issues and trying so many things and
then seeing certain things that just
didn't change they were like we're going
to try other things now clearly in
places which have more extremely
authoritarian governments you have a
whole variety of different techniques in
which people turn to protest I mean you
can have everything from you know the
mothers in Argentina
earn to just a silent witness almost as
a way to highlight the disparity between
their suffering and what the Pinochet
government was willing to do and in
other places you can have violent
uprisings in which people try to
overthrow the state by force like the
check yes may be an example right now in
America I don't feel like we've had that
kind of like huge shift I mean we've had
subtle of course changes in Republican
Democrat governments but to me they
haven't been so extreme to change the
whole method what has changed is the
legal climate our acceptance of
different forms of political
participation over time and that's
definitely left led to more a wider
variety of styles of protests that are
possible I mean these different Supreme
Court rulings coming in since the 1930s
have definitely established this notion
of a public forum that before that the
first amendment was not interpreted that
way so that has you know helped change
and that's not because the Supreme Court
saw the light but it was us because
people took to the streets so
you